on the surface physics can seem like a
very tedious subject and I've thought
that before myself it is taught as a way
to protect and describe the physical
world
but that in itself should be far from
boring because we live in a very
exciting place I used to just want to be
a writer because I saw writing as a more
creative subject in science but it
wasn't long before I found poetry and
maths and physics there is a beautiful
theorem called know--this theorem which
talks about the symmetries to be found
in physical systems my inspiration as a
physics student comes from finding
beauty in things that would otherwise
seem mundane a mirror symmetry is where
you fold an object in half and it
perfectly mirrors itself but you can
have other kinds of symmetry such as
taking an object and moving it along
rotating it or waiting a while and it's
still the same when I say the same I
mean the total energy is still the same
so energy can come in a few different
forms
you could have potential energy kinetic
or movement energy sound or heat but as
long as the total remains the same then
a change has been symmetric what
know--this theorem does is it looks at
these imaginary changes or
transformations to find out real things
about an object's behavior what we find
out about is something called
conservation laws you might have heard
that momentum is conserved
well momentum is something's mass times
its velocity or speed so it's how much
motion an object has if a change has
been symmetric under a transformation so
the total energy stayed the same and
that means the total momentum will also
be conserved where and stay the same if
though you only have a change that is
Schmitt
in one axis of rotation it means the
angular momentum in that direction is
conserved these kind of laws work for
symmetries and time as well by looking
at symmetries in nature we can find out
interesting things about quantities we
know must stay the same under some
change and we can work backwards as well
if we find out that something has been
conserved we know that there must be
some underlying symmetry present this
comes in handy when we are probing down
to things like quantum mechanics and
figuring out what it is that were made
of and how it all holds together